another game that we knew about because
it leaked just before it went out but
grow grow up I'm really proud because
you suffer flexions are from Newcastle
so having a Geordie on stage was
incredible game the cutest little cutie
platformer um I don't know if I'm I'll
play it but I'm not really hyped about
it it's it's you know doesn't have the
same impact of something like child of
light where you kind of seeing just are
immediately mesmerised but yeah girl
home was it was a cute fun little game
and it seems like grow grow up is going
to you know expand on the same mechanics
so I faith that the teams can do
something really clever and really cute
endearing with it so I mean yeah I will
certainly play it again I agree with you
it's like you can't get quite as hyped
about that as maybe some of the other
stuff they showed but yeah no I'm happy
it's in there to a nice have a game
that's not just like blood and gore and
violence over time like you need a bit
of a palate cleanser every now and then
go home was it was a surprise for a lot
of people daily and it came out of
nowhere and it was out before you knew
it and everyone that played it were like
wow this is actually really quite cute
and the thing that's good really going
to like sell it for for this one is how
far they go with it whether they
overextend or not like I'm hoping that
they just it looks like they've
introduced a few new ideas and spread
out the you know made the environment
that you exploring a little bigger and
hopefully it's just that like still
maybe like a four or five our experience
and it doesn't try to be this big long
you know yeah ending things because if
they can keep it short and sweet again
they can recapture some of that kind of
you know shock and all that you get all
from a game that just appears out of
nowhere so it's all about how big their
kind of going with it hopefully and then
after that we had trials of the Blood
Dragon I think when everyone saw the guy
from trials and dean evans ago from
blood dry can come out the kind of you
already carry me what you're in for um
what do we think has the trials bulk
kind of sailed now I don't know it's
interesting because trousers a game that
classically makes a lot of people like
super super tense especially those later
levels they are yes epically hard hmm
but then Blood Dragon also makes
everyone so happy because it's so kooky
crazy it's all the nostalgia fuel that
we adore so combining something that
makes people so gleeful and let and
happy with something that can really
make your skin crawl with frustration
it's going to be interesting to see how
it were
especially with all the new additions
they had guns in there and there are
people on foot at times I don't know how
they're gonna actually it calls yeah
exactly gonna blend those two types of
gameplay I to be honest I absolutely
love trials evolution so I'm kind of
hoping that this can it scratch those
itches pour it up but with jnana dragons
pretty much